did can occur in many ways like people
died out of cancer AIDS people die out
of heart attack or a road accident
similarly in cell biology the death of
the cell can occur in several ways and
there are several ways of cell death in
this particular video we would focus on
one of the cell death types which is
called type 3 cell death or necrosis so
in this whole video we would look at the
features of necrosis how it is a little
bit different from apoptosis and its
types so let's begin let's say this is
an epithelial tissue and in this
particular tissue the region which is
marked in red and having a redness in
this particular region there is an
attack due to a mechanical injury or
maybe there is a injury by any pathogen
or any other disease what happens is
this cell dies and spills out it's all
cytoplasm its membrane integrity gets
lost and it spills over all of its
internal content and influencing its
nearby cells this type of cell death is
classically known as necrosis which is
pretty much uncontrolled the cell which
is dying it has no control that how much
it's rich in inside material would
affect the other cells and also the
pathway by which the cells are dying
it's not pretty much controlled this
particular type of death is known as
necrosis now let's talk about the
hallmarks of necrosis the homeworks of
necrosis includes first it is always
related to a pathological situation
earlier we talked about apoptosis
but apoptosis could occur under normal
circumstances like for development
during development the body or the city
system might want to get rid of certain
cell types and that's why it would
undergo a programmed cell death but
necrosis as far as its concerned it is
always associated with any kind of
pathology
situation any kind of damage any kind of
irreversible injury to the cell now
always it creates an inflammation or
inflammatory response in the surrounding
tissue it really affects the surrounding
tissue and it's a collective cell death
it's like it's not that one cell is
dying because apoptotic mechanisms are
pretty much precise but these kind of
necrotic cell mechanisms necrotic cell
death mechanisms are pretty much
uncontrolled then the cell death type is
not programmed there are not sequential
ways by which the cell dies I mean it's
still debated but what people really
think is the cell dead program is not
defined now let's see a healthy cell we
can see this is a particular healthy
epithelial cell it has lysosomes
mitochondria er gali everything intact
let's look at what happens when the cell
is undergoing necrosis what changes
takes place inside the cell at a
morphological level at a molecular and a
cellular level first and foremost what
happens is the mitochondria of the cells
localized in a weird fashion in a very
nuclear way and it forms a very nuclear
ring like this shown in the figure
now other thing is the mitochondria
suffers from swelling the mitochondria
swells and it's morphology is very
different from a normal one and
surprisingly not only its morphology its
functionality is also altered which we
would talk about and this is one of the
major cause associated with the necrotic
pathway now one of the biggest changes
that takes place in the mitochondria is
the Christie the in terment the inner
membrane invaginations more the number
of Christie the more functional
mitochondria it would be because there
could be more electron transport chain
and everything but here in case of
necrosis
the mitochondria really swells up and
its inner membrane surface area is
reduced
other than that lysosome disruption or
lysosome rupture is a big problem in
necrosis when lysosome is ruptured and
it set its content is released in the
cytoplasm then occurs a big problem
because lysosome is a bag full of
hydrolytic enzymes
now this hydrolytic enzymes are pretty
much potent and always remained in a
membrane mount situation it's never
released but once it is released it
would affect cells inner workings or
inner pathways or inner structures right
that's why lysosomal rupture is a
hallmark feature of necrosis second is
like and one of the most important
feature is the plasma membrane rupture
or plasma membrane integrity loss you
can see here the plasma membrane is
losing its integrity leaking and as a
result the cytoplasmic material is
leaking out and reaching the surrounding
this is a hallmark feature which never
occurs in there pop ptosis in case of
apoptosis things are very different
let's it's a normal cell in case of
apoptosis the cells would shrink in size
and it would blade out but each of these
small plates are actually membrane bound
component which has their own organelles
and stuff like that but the membrane
integrity is never lost which is a
hallmark feature in case of necrosis
ammendment integrities corners becomes
more leaky so we pretty much looked at
while at the morphological changes let's
look at the molecular changes the first
and the foremost thing to be discussed
is the calcium overload normally cell
has very stringent mechanism by which it
can buffer the calcium levels and
maintaining a level of proper level of
calcium is super important for the cells
functioning and the signaling as well
because calcium is important second
messengers right but the calcium
overload leads to many excitotoxin fact
into the cell and we would learn it
about later specially this is super
harmful for the neurons
because for neuron monitoring it's
excitability is a form most important
job for the neuron and if there is a dis
balance in the calcium concentration it
has been reported the neuron undergoes
excited rock six cell death or excited
rock signal necrosis then reactive
oxygen production is another big problem
in the necrotic pathway because you know
the mitochondrial function is gone or
mitochondria are dysmorphic they are
swelling up and it's expected the
microglia won't function in a proper way
and it would generate more Ross which is
harmful for that cell itself Ross can do
lipid peroxidation and thereby changing
the membrane integrity other than that
ATP concentration is going down as the
mitochondria is not that much functional
and the cell has less energy to come in
meet up its metabolic processes together
everything is messed up in case of
necrosis all the inner physiological
processes are makes messed up more than
that the when the ATP levels are super
low on top of that there is a decoupling
between the electron transport chain and
ATP production which is even worse and
making the ATP level even lower so cell
is undergoing a huge metabolic crisis
not only that in that situation when TCA
cycle is absent cell try to cope up and
the pyruvate is converted to lactate now
left-- is super acidic it produced the
pH of the cytosol and that low pH is
harmful for the enzymes that are present
in the cytosol they get deactivated
which are important for damaged cells
normal physiology in this way has a
combined effect of all these cellular
and molecular features the cell
progressively moves towards its death
which is the necrosis now we can talk
about other features of necrosis one of
most pronounced feature is the Proteus
activation these Proteus are other than
gas phases these are cal pain and
cathepsin which are also potent protease
and can cause damage to the cell other
than that there is another molecule
called cyclic film D which is getting
activated in case of necrosis in this
situation mitochondrial permeability
transient pore complex is opening and
many of the mitochondrial enzyme still
leaking out cytochrome C is leaking out
and mitochondrial functionality is
heavily altered under this process
moreover there is a dissipation of the
proton gradient that's why a deep
reproduction cannot be triggered any
more which is due to the uncoupling and
also there is a alternation in the
membrane potential of the mitochondria
combining all of these fact we can
understand how the cell dies now when
cell dies it releases this content in
the surrounding and these damaged
particles which are produced by the
bursting of this cell and these are
known as damage associated molecular
patterns this really creates an
inflammatory response and really
attracts many of the innate immune cells
such as macrophages and the dendritic
cell to the damaged site or to the site
of the cell type
now this macrophage and dendritic cell
are phagocytic so they would try to take
out the debris but also they have
toll-like receptors which recognize this
damage associated molecular patterns in
response to that macrophage and
dendritic cells secrete several
pro-inflammatory cytokine this prohibit
inflammatory cytokine work like at
alarming signal bringing in more innate
immune cells more macrophages and
dendritic cell to the site of location
due to the site and also it can lead to
neutrophil extravasation to the tissue
site where there is a necrosis happening
all these things really elevates the
inflammatory response now
let's just summarize the key features of
necrosis that we have learned so far so
first we have seen the membrane
disruption is very unique for necrosis
which does not take place in apoptosis
lysosomal dysfunction Proteus activation
like health pains and Khattab scenes
mitochondrial dysfunction and frost
generation was a hallmark feature of
necrosis then necrosis is always
associated to our inflammatory response
and other immune component activation so
that pretty much summarized why necrosis
what are the molecular and cellular
features of necrosis now let's talk
about a little bit about the types of
necrosis since I have already talked
about that the necrosis is always
associated with some kind of pathology
so these types are actually based on the
pathology they are associated with one
type of necrosis is coagulative necrosis
as the name suggests some kind of
coagulation is associated with it or
clotting is associated with it and when
chlorine comes in your mind you can
generally think of ischemia in case of
ischemia this kind of necrotic mechanism
take place other than that there is
liquid fact if necrosis it always takes
place when there is an abscess
there is also fungal infection mediated
see Isis and there is fibrin oyd type of
necrosis where there is a blood clot
related a pathology which leads to death
in that small blood vessel cells or like
that so that pathology is known as
fibrin oyd necrosis and last but not the
least there is gangrenous neck crosses
it normally happens in the lower limbs
and you can see how bad it is and how
the lower limb and in some cases the
lower limb has to be amputated so in
this video we pretty much summarized the
cellular and molecular changes during
necrosis we also looked at the types and
taken some example to understand the
process of necrosis or this kind of type
3 cell that mechanism in a detail so I
hope you enjoyed this video if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you